you did a sketch where you played a
football player who kept getting
penalized for doing pelvic thrusts
what's his name he hangul mccringleberry
yeah and stay yeah and and really funny
sketch I think we have do we have a clip
of this I just want to show this yeah
Kringle Barry you think he's happy
oh boy is loving it down there oh we got
something of a shooting gallery
celebration policy and I'm not sure
about that cause I don't know bill that
was three pumps and the rulebook says
you cannot have more than two the rep
gets right down by your crystal and he's
looking at it to see if there's give me
another one okay that was funny doing a
comedy sketch here's the part where gets
bizarre real NFL players right started
doing that move right it sort of in it
just sorta giving you a shout out yeah
and then they were getting fun they were
definitely a sketch so yes Von Miller
got fined last year and Antonio Brown
got fined this year and so now I think
the next call is gonna be from Roger
Goodell directly to my house yeah your
do it they're doing it because you sort
of taught them how to do it right you
know I think Von Miller was fined eleven
eleven thousand five hundred and sixty
seven dollars that's right for doing
that doing that right so I would think
it'd be some anger towards you right
well what happened is we got so or
denied are so afraid of Von Miller we
paid the fine we actually paid you guys
pay the fine that we and then we donated
money to his his eyeglass the Denver but
mostly because we were scared to death
that he was going to come and get us
yeah ya know cuz eleven thousand dollars
that's a lot of money for a professional
football player
you